J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK.
I want to start with a
question that was asked
by Ayesha after the last lecture
regarding fractional-order
of kinetics.
You remember that in the
reaction of methyllithium
there was a pre-equilibrium
between the tetramer and the
monomer so that tetramer is
dominant, but
the monomer is reactive.
So remember what that meant was
that in this
pre-equilibrium the rate of
association equals the rate of
disassociation.
So the concentration of monomer
to the fourth power is
proportional to that of the
tetramer.
Or if you take the fourth roots
on each side it says
that the concentration of the
reactive species is one-fourth
power in the amount of material
you actually add,
which is the dominant tetramer.
What Ayesha pointed out is this
seemed to be similar to
the case of a radical-chain
initiator, which also had a
fractional order.
Remember the idea was that the
initiator breaks to give two
radicals, then the radical
abstracts a hydrogen to give
the radical, which is part of
the cyclic mechanism in the
radical-chain, the propagation
steps of the
free-radical reaction.
But ultimately the machines are
destroyed by two radicals
getting together in the
termination process, either
forming X-X or X with R or R
with R.
So at first glance this doesn't
look very similar to
the equilibrium on the top.
This isn't an equilibrium at
all.
You're not going back to the
starting material, you're not
getting back to the peroxide.
So this one is an example of a
steady state instead of an
equilibrium.
So when the initiation is
constantly going on, the
machine gets into a steady state
of how fast it's going
around and disappearing at the
same time, then you have the
amount of termination equals the
amount of initiation.
So you have a steady amount of
this, which is going to
determine the rate of the
reaction of the machine.
And since the termination is
proportional to the
concentration of radical
squared, the radical could be
in the form either of X atom or
in the
form of the R radical'.
But whatever it is, when two of
them get
together that does it.
So the radical's concentration
squared, how much machine
there is squared, is
proportional to the
initiation, to the concentration
of this.
So this isn't an equilibrium, as
it was in the top.
But really it's the same deal.
The number of machines then is
proportional to the square
root of the amount of the
initiator.
And notice that this is the
same-- association equals
disassociation implies this
relationship, termination
equals initiation implies this
relationship.
So really they are the same
thing, even though when she
asked me the question I thought
they
were completely different.
So I've been teaching this for
45 years or something like
that, and it never occurred to
me that these fundamentally
were the same thing, the reason
you have this
fractional-order kinetics.
So this was a simplification and
generalization that Ayesha
came up with, and that's what
constitutes progress in
science is when instead of
having to memorize a zillion
things, you find out they're all
the same and you
just know that one.
So congratulations to Ayesha,
and keep up the good work all
you people.
That's what makes it fun to
teach you.
After x years of teaching this
I'm still learning.
And I also ask questions.
So on the 2009 exam I asked
consider this chlorination
reaction-- the one we talked
about at
the end of last lecture--
and certain bond dissociation
energies, and then you're
supposed to figure out various
things.
But part G of this many-part
question was why should the
bond disassociation energies of
N-Cl and R-Cl be so
different, when those of N-H and
R-H are so similar?
So N-Cl is 46, N-H is 92, twice
as big.
R-Cl and R-H are about the same
energy.
Why is that?
Well, the answer I expected was
based on this-
lone-pair repulsion.
So here on the left we have
peroxide and ethane.
They have the same number of
electrons.
And on the right we have N-Cl
and methyl-Cl, the same number
of electrons on the right.
Now if you look at the bond
disassociation energies, this
one is twice as strong as that
one, and this one is nearly
twice as strong as that one.
So what makes the ones on the
top so weak when really it's
the same number of electrons
involved up and down?
Well, what you notice is that on
top you have lone pairs on
the atoms that are being bonded,
which
will repel one another.
So the idea I expected was that
that
would weaken the bond.
Now is this plausible?
Could the electron-pair
repulsion explain the
difference in bond
disassociation energies
between the top and bottom?
Well, we can look at how the
electrons actually are
arranged, as we calculate it by
quantum mechanics.
And, of course, what it looks
like depends on
what contour we draw.
This contour at 0.002 electrons
per cubic Bohr
radius is not very informative.
But if we go in further to
higher densities to 0.01 to
0.05 to 0.25, now we see
something different in these
two things.
You notice that in the bottom,
the protons that are out here,
the proton on the carbon, as
opposed to where there is no
proton on the oxygen, draws
these electrons out.
And the same thing here.
The hydrogen that's pulled out
of the nitrogen nucleus and
put out here to become CH3, that
draws these electrons out
so that they don't repel one
another as much.
So that seems a plausible
explanation, although it's not
quantitative.
So we would say then that the
repulsion between the
electrons, which is less in the
case where they've been
drawn out might be an important
factor in
stabilizing the ones where the
electrons are drawn out.
That was the answer I expected
on the exam because we had
talked about lone- pair
repulsion.
So that seems a plausible
explanation for weakening O-O
versus C-C or N-Cl versus C-Cl.
But that wasn't the answer I got
on a lot of the--
some people gave that answer,
but a lot of them appealed to
the difference of
electronegativity, so that
C-Cl has a big difference in the
electronegativity,
according to the Pauling scale
of electronegativity.
So carbon has 2.55, chlorine
3.16--
they're quite different in their
electronegativity,
whereas nitrogen at 3.04 is
rather similar to the 3.16.
So what people had in mind then
was there'd be an
important resonance structure
for C-Cl that would be C+
Cl-, and that would be-- we
associate the existence of
resonance structures with
stabilization.
Now we've seen that we can
understand that thing in terms
of the energies of orbitals, the
concept that
was involved there.
We start with a bond either with
nitrogen to chlorine,
which would have its electrons
there or carbon to chlorine,
down there.
And then if we're going to break
the bond, those
electrons, if we're going to go
to ions, like N+ or C+
and Cl-, these electron pairs
would have to
go onto the chlorine.
And they have to go farther when
they're on the nitrogen.
So that mismatch in energies
aids breaking them
heterolytically for the carbon
case.
Where the carbon is mismatched,
you don't have to go up as
much, so it's easier to ionize.
But that's not what we're
talking about in bond
dissociation energy.
In bond dissociation energy
we're talking about breaking
to two free radicals where one
goes on one atom, one electron
goes on the other from the pair.
And now, as we talked about
early last semester in terms
of bond disassociation energy or
homolysis, it's the
carbon-chlorine bond is
stronger.
'So this is putting slightly
more quantitative ideas to
bear on the idea of why you have
that
difference in bond strength.
But the idea of
electronegativity being
associated with bond strength is
an interesting one that's
worth tracing down a little bit.
So I'm going to talk just a
little bit today about
electronegativity and bond
strength.
The first use--
I mentioned this last semester
in English--
of the word electronegativity
was in 1837 in System of
Mineralogy by James Dwight Dana.
And we mentioned that James
Dwight Dana was a professor
here at Yale in the nineteenth
century.
He lived in this house that
you've walked by, which is now
a national historical monument.
And he lived in the house with
his wife, Henrietta Dana.
Actually, it was Henrietta
Silliman Dana
was her maiden name.
And she was the daughter of
Benjamin Silliman, whose
statue is just down past Nate
out there, as you see him on
the way up.
I think his snow necklace is
gone this week.
So Dana was well married.
That's just to give you a little
local color.
But electronegativity in the
sense we use it.
What sense would Dana have been
involved in
electronegativity?
In 1837 what idea was going
around where the negativity or
positivity of atoms would be
important?
STUDENT: Dualism.
PROFESSOR: Dualism, right.
The idea of what held things
together.
He thought if you could
understand what was negative
and what was positive then you
could understand
minerals in that case.
But electronegativity in the
sense of organic chemistry, or
inorganic chemistry for that
matter, was popularized by
Linus Pauling, beginning with
this paper in 1933--
or 1932 it was published.
So this is a key passage in that
paper.
And remember that Pauling was
pushing this idea of
resonance--
that you get stabilization when
you can draw different
resonance structures.
So he's talking about the
additivity of the energies of
normal covalent bonds.
He says, "There's empirical
evidence in support of the
postulate that the energies of
normal covalent bonds are
additive." Now what does he mean
by additive?
That is, that if you have atoms
A and B, you could have
AA, you could have AB, BB, and
you could have AB.
And his idea is that the bond
strength in AB should be the
average of what you have in AA
and what you have in BB.
So he was a little confusing
about that, because in some
papers he used this concept
using the arithmetic mean, but
in others he talked about the
geometric mean where it was
the square root of the product
instead of half the sum.
But at any rate, the idea was
that normal covalent bonds
should be the average of the
homonuclear bonds.
So he uses, then, this plot
where he's measuring the
energies of the bonds, bond
disassociation energies, in
unusual units for us, electron
volts.
You multiply by 23 to get
kilocalories per mole.
So here are H-X bonds that are
normal, that is, calculated if
they were normal.
They're the average of the H-H
and the X-X for the different
halogens, as you see, fluorine,
chlorine, bromine
and iodine.
Now incidentally, there's a
little problem here because he
was using the wrong value for
the fluorine-fluorine bond
energy in all of this work.
He thought it was 65
kilocalories per mole;
actually it's 38.
It's a rather weak bond because
of all these electron-pair
repulsions that we talked about.
So his numbers are a little bit
skewed, but at any rate,
that was what he was doing.
So this is theoretical.
To get these red numbers he used
H-H and X-X and just took
their average.
Now observed values are this;
the bonds are actually
stronger than you expect.
But they're not all stronger by
the same amount.
And the reason is in Pauling's
theory, this resonance theory,
that you could have the polar
resonance structure, which
makes it more stable.
What this suggests is that
there's this difference,
delta, between what you would
expect if it were normal, the
average, and what you observe,
which is what you have when
you have this polar resonance
structure.
And what he says here, the
greater the ionic character of
the bond the greater will be the
value of delta.
So the neat idea now is we could
use delta, which is
based on experimental numbers,
as a way to measure how
important resonance is.
So you could measure resonance
stabilization by delta, if you
adopt his assumptions that
normal bonds are the average,
and now you measure these and
the difference tells you how
important resonance
stabilization is.
And then you try to see if
there's something you can
correlate to predict how
important resonance
stabilization should be.
So he has his rather complicated
Table 2 in the
paper, which has observed bond
energies, normal bond
energies, delta, and the square
root of delta.
Now let's show how that works by
taking one
particular block here.
So we're comparing oxygen and
fluorine.
So here on the table we look at
oxygen-oxygen, and its bond
dissociation energy is 1.49
electron volts.
Or you can look over here and
fluorine-fluorine is 2.80.
So if the bond were normal the
oxygen-fluorine bond would be
the average of those.
Although remember, actually this
is 1.65, it's not 2.80.
But put that aside for now.
Then if you look at oxygen with
fluorine, the bond
disassociation energy observed
is 2.48.
Now we could compare that.
Notice it's not the average of
1.49 and 2.80.
It's too high.
So we could calculate what the
normal would be, what the
average is of O-O and F-F.
And then we can take the
difference.
The difference is 0.33--
that's delta.
That's how much, in his view,
the O-F bond has been
stabilized because of the
resonance structure.
Now is there a way to predict
how big that delta should be?
Well, here's the same deal with
carbon and fluorine.
And notice that the delta for
carbon and fluorine is 2.20--
much bigger than between oxygen
and fluorine,
which was only 0.33.
Or you could look in a different
block and see what
it is for carbon and oxygen,
it's 1.0.
So we know carbon to oxygen how
much it is, we know carbon
to fluorine how much it is, and
we know oxygen to fluorine
how big it is.
Is there some relationship among
these that we could--
knowing two of them we could
have predicted the third.
Well, not really, because the
difference between C and F and
minus difference between C and O
is not the difference
between O and F. It doesn't
work.
You can't add up the polarity
differences that way.
But then he tried something
else.
He tried taking the square root
of delta.
That's the brown numbers here.
So this is a square root of
those stabilizations.
And now you see something
interesting.
That the difference between C-O
and C-F is the difference
between O and F, pretty close.
So the square roots are about
additive.
Now I don't think he had any
good reason theoretically to
say it should be the square
root.
But he fiddled with the numbers
and he
noticed that worked.
So the question is does it work
for all the elements?
If so, then from some you can
predict the others.
So here he has the square roots
of delta for carbon
versus other things.
That is, how important is the
resonance structure, the
square root of the stabilization
of the bond.
How important is that for C-H,
for C-N, for C-O, for C-F, for
C-Cl, for C-Br?
And can we use that to establish
a scale of how
different the polarities are
among those different atoms?
So here he has carbon, and
here's hydrogen on one side,
then bromine, chlorine and
nitrogen, oxygen and fluorine
on the other side.
And the distances there are
those numbers we just saw on
the previous slide.
How important after taking the
square root is that energy
difference, that stabilization.
So we did it with carbon.
So you get some values.
But if those values are
fundamental, then you should
get the same scale no matter
what atom you used.
You don't have to do carbon-X,
you could do nitrogen-X or
oxygen-X or anything else X, and
you should always get the
same scale, if this system is
going to work.
So that's these other horizontal
lines.
Notice that in the case of
carbon the difference between
carbon and oxygen is 1, the
difference between carbon and
fluorine is 1.48, and then the
difference between oxygen and
fluorine is 0.48.
And experimentally, if you
measure relative to oxygen,
oxygen to fluorine is 0.58, not
bad.
So here are the others compared
to oxygen for the O-X
bonds, and here they are
relative to hydrogen.
And notice that as you come down
with oxygen, fluorine,
chlorine, nitrogen, bromine,
carbon,
they're sort of the same.
It's the same order and they're
about the same.
So this isn't the last word in
theory.
But it looks like something
pretty fundamental.
And then here he used relative
to both H on one end
and F on the other.
So he called these things, this
scale, electronegativity.
And here he gives the increasing
electronegativity,
which is just those numbers, the
square root of the
stabilization of the bond from
the previous slide, and here
are the values for hydrogen,
phosphorous, iodine, sulfur,
carbon and so on.
And these were the days when
they still did hand-written
figures in the Journal of the
American Chemical Society,
which was a long time ago.
And then below that, he looks
at--
I couldn't figure out for a long
time what the heck this
was, but finally I figured out--
he
doesn't say in the paper--
but it's a picture of the
periodic table, which has been
distorted so that it shows every
atom at its proper
electronegativity.
So here are the halogens, here
are the chalcogenides,
nitrogen, phosphorous, carbon
and so on.
In other words, he's taken the
periodic table and he's
distorted it like that so that
the numbers go from red to
yellow, as you go from left to
right.
So that's where
electronegativity in the
current sense--
the Pauling scale of
electronegativity, that's
where it came from.
And notice that what it really
depends on, is what the
periodic table depends on, is
that as you go across here, you
have the nuclear charge is
increasing.
The screened nuclear charge-- we
talked
about that last semester.
And as you go down, the number
of nodes in the valence shell
is increasing.
That's what gives the periodic
table its character, that's
what explains
electronegativities.
So the idea of this was to push
the concept of resonance.
Now is it surprising that we
find that bond strength
correlates with differences in
Pauling's electronegativities?
Remember, the chi-sub-P' is
Pauling's
electronegativity values.
Remember how we got into this
question?
We said why are these polar
bonds like N-Cl unusually weak
compared to bonds that don't
have that difference in
electronegativity?
And we said it was repulsion of
electron pairs, but some
people said it's
electronegativity.
Now I ask you, is it surprising
here that bond
strength correlates with
Pauling's
electronegativity scale?
Has anybody have an opinion on
that after
what I have been saying?
I've gone through this pretty
fast, so I don't expect you
to, but I was impressed by the
question I got after last
lecture, so I thought I'd give
it a try here.
Nate?
STUDENT: No, because you used
the bond strengths to
determine--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, no.
Because that's where the
electronegativities came from
in Pauling.
Remember, it's the square root
of the bond strength
stabilization that he used to
get the
electronegativity scale.
So it's not surprising at all
Nate, you're exactly right.
The Pauling electronegativity
scale was defined by the
differences in bond strengths
from the averages.
Now in the first issue of Nature
this year--this year
has been proclaimed the
International Year of
Chemistry, so you're sitting in
the right class here.
So the first issue of Nature was
celebrating chemistry and
they had a bunch of essays.
And one of them on pages 26 to
28 was by Philip Ball, and it
was called "Beyond The Bond"
Have we moved beyond bonds now--
can we just use quantum
mechanics to talk about things?
Remember, this was the question
we asked at the end
of last semester.
If the history of chemistry
hadn't developed the way that
it did in terms of bonds, and we
just had quantum mechanics,
would anybody ever have talked
about bonds, if you could just
calculate all these numbers?
And the little squib about this
article said, "More than
ever before, new techniques show
the bonds to be a
convenient fiction, albeit one
that holds the field of
chemistry together, finds Philip
Ball."
But one passage in that I
thought was
particularly timely.
He said, "By the 1960s, for all
Pauling's salesmanship, MO
theory was generally agreed to
be more convenient than his
resonance theory for most
purposes."
So when I was a student,
resonance theory was a really
big thing and molecular orbital
theory
was just coming on.
But it's really different now.
Now molecular orbital theory is
what people mostly focus
on, and only certain communities
tend
to talk about resonance.
But elementary teaching tends to
lag behind
where people are.
So resonance is still a big
thing in AP courses I
suspect, and so on.
But any rate, it's not
surprising really.
Certainly it's not surprising as
you correlate with
Pauling's scale, because that's
what he used to define
bond strengths.
But the idea of polar bonds
having high bond dissociation
energy in terms of what we
talked about first, how far
the electrons have to go up when
you break the bond to get
two free radicals, we expect
that energy mismatch will
strengthen bonds.
So accrued correlation of the
Pauling electronegativity
scale plotted vertically with
other measures of how tightly
electrons are held, the orbital
energy.
For example, how much energy it
takes to pull an electron
away from an atom.
Or how much energy does it take
to pull an electron away
from a charged ion.
Both of those things are
measures of orbital energy.
And that's what's called
Mulliken's electronegativity
scale, which he published two
years later in 1934, the
average of ionization potential
and electron affinity.
So this one, Mulliken was one of
the chief originators of
molecular orbital theory, which
in the middle of the
century was in real competition.
It was a little bit like radical
theory and type theory
100 years earlier.
There was a lot of competition
between them.
But Mulliken's theory, which has
to do with orbital energy
we can understand, and we see
that it correlates more or
less well with Pauling's
electronegativity scale.
So fine.
So electronegativity does have
something to do with it, but
electronegativity really is not
sort of
a fundamental property.
It was measured in terms of
these bond stabilizations.
OK, that's just a little bit of
a sidelight to what we're
actually talking about.
The chemistry and physics of
alkyl halides we're going to
talk about now.
Free-radical halogenation
introduces a functional group
into alkanes.
Normal alkanes don't have a
functional group, unusually
high HOMO or low LUMO.
Once you've done a free-radical
reaction on
those, now you have this
unusually low LUMO,
sigma*, so you could begin doing
things with it.
So what we're going to talk
about now, having talked about
free-radical reactions, is the
ionic chemistry involving that
sigma*.
So we're going to talk about the
alkyl halides, which now
we know how to prepare.
So these are nucleophilic
substitution, and acidity is
much the same thing.
We mentioned this preliminarily
last semester.
So there are non-bonded
interactions and solvation,
which is key for ionic
reactions.
And I just noticed that all the
work I did since last
night is not in here because
I've re-done that slide.
So the question is am I going to
put that in here or not?
It would take about two
seconds--
well, it'll take about a minute
to break here and start
again with the most recent
version, which I can't
sacrifice all the work I did
since last night.
I stayed up late.
So I'm going to save this.
Pardon me.
Because by mistake this morning
I loaded the version
that was on the web.
OK, I've got that saved now,
nearly.
Oh, it's saving it over the web,
that's the problem.
I hadn't reckoned on that one.
Are there any questions while
we're pausing for this?
Just incidentally, how much did
you learn about
electronegativity in high
school?
Was this a big focus of your AP
course?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So now you know where
it came from-- it came
from Dana down the hill, and
then Pauling.
There we go now.
I want the other version that's
here I think.
So I'm going to do that last
slide again because that's
where I noticed things were bad.
So free-radical halogenation
introduces a functional group.
And we're going to now be
looking at that functional
group, the chemical and physical
properties of alkyl
halides, which involve sigma*,
the functional
group we've been able to put in.
So we have SN1 reactions at
which those electrons go onto
X in order to break the bond.
And we have those in which the
new electrons have gone into
sigma* in order to help the X
leave, and that's the
SN2' reaction.
And if the atom in the middle is
H instead of R, then this
same thing is acidity.
We introduced this concept last
semester, but we're going
to talk about it in more detail
in terms of reaction
mechanisms now.
Now in the process, this makes
ions.
So we have to go beyond the
molecules themselves in
thinking about this reaction.
Because non-bonded interactions
and solvation
turns out to be key for ionic
reactions.
You can't just look at the
reacting species, you have to
look at the surroundings, which
makes everything ever so
much more complicated.
Now this Henri Victor Regnault,
who lived, as you
see, in the middle of nineteenth
century.
And you know the first letter of
his last name because it
said that that's where they R
comes from, it stands for
Regnault because he did a lot of
thermodynamic stuff.
So PV equals nRT is this man.
Now in 1850 he wrote a book, The
First Elements of
Chemistry, and there's one
passage about chemical
affinity here that I think is
worth looking at.
He says, "For chemical affinity
to act freely,
substances must be dispersed."
Now this was, of course, writing
in 1850 this was
before bonds or anything.
But they knew you don't you just
mix solids together; you
have to disperse them.
And you can't just grind them.
"Since dispersion by mechanical
pulverization is
incomplete," the molecules have
to touch molecules, not
just particles of stuff touch
particles.
"They must be taken into the
liquid or gaseous state.
Previous chemists expressed this
fact by saying, 'Corpera
non agunt, nisi soluta.'"
Substances do not react unless
they're dissolved.
So this dissolution, the fact of
what's around the things is
what's going to be important in
understanding reactions.
So the theory of organic
chemistry became manageable in
the first place when people
started studying
gases, as you remember.
Because it's often possible to
focus on the simple unit with
strong interactions, that's
molecules are the individual
units, and bonds within them are
the strong interactions
with well-defined geometries and
energies, as we discussed
last semester.
And you neglect the much more
numerous and complex
intermolecular interactions with
the solvent.
But actually we're going to have
to consider those,
because we're interested not
just in the gas
phase but in solution.
So it was essential to go into
the gas phase in order to get
a toe-hold on understanding
chemistry in the first place.
But if you want to understand
real practical chemistry you
have to understand solutions.
So these weak intermolecular
interactions give organic
materials many of their most
valuable properties.
Most of the properties of what's
important in your
bodies are not things that
involve making and breaking
bonds, but changing non-bonded
interactions between things.
And that's what we're going to
be looking at for a
little while now.
So non-bonded classical
energies.
Now suppose you have just
Coulomb's law, charge-charge
interaction--
that's where we started last
semester.
That's, as you know, the only
true source of chemical
potential energy.
There's gravity and physics of
magnetism, but those are tiny.
They're nothing compared to
Coulomb's law.
There's the strong force--
that's for physicists, that's
way above what we
deal with in chemistry.
The Coulomb's law is where we
live.
And it's proportional to 1 over
R as we know.
And the constant for the
proportionality is -300, 332
kilocalories per mole when you
use angstrom units.
So this provides a very long
range attraction.
Even when you're 3Å' apart, the
energy is still 100
kilocalories per mole.
Actually, now where should we
start with zero?
We could start with zero when
they're infinitely far away,
and then we use Coulomb's law to
get how
the energy goes down.
Or if we're thinking of breaking
the bond we could
start at the bond distance, or
the distance between two ions,
and see how much it takes to
pull them
apart a certain distance.
So a bond is 1.5, let's take
bigger.
Let's suppose they're 2 Å'
apart.
That means they're at 332 over
2.
The energy is -165.
If we go to 3 Å' then it's -100.
So we've gone up in energy by
about 100 kilocalories per
mole in going from 2 to 3 Å'.
And we have a
lot further to go on the way
out.
This is very different from
covalent bonds where when you
get to 3 Å' that's the end of
the line.
So covalent bonds are typically
100 kilocalories per
mole, but you get there very
quickly.
So they're very stiff.
As you break the bond, you go up
in energy really quickly.
Coulomb doesn't go up as
rapidly, but it goes
up very, very far.
So it's long range.
And that's why solvents are so
important, because another
molecule can be rather far away
and still influence ions
where it wouldn't influence
free-radicals.
But this is attenuated by a
solvent.
If you have a dielectric
constant, as it's called, in
the solvent, that reduces the
magnitude of the Coulombic
energy or the Coulombic force.
Now how big are these values of
epsilon?
Here are some values taken from
the Jones book.
Notice that hexane is a factor
of 2.
So that'll take that constant
from 300 down to 150--
still quite big.
But if you go to something like
water at 78,
that cuts it way down.
This into this is something like
4.
So it's only 4 kilocalories per
mole rather than 332
kilocalories per mole, if your
operating in water, with water
all around the ions.
So that's makes an enormous
difference how these ions are
going to interact, what solvent
you're in.
It makes quite a difference what
solvent.
And notice down to acetone, the
solvents might be
considered polar--
that is, they have pretty big
dielectric constants.
So they really attenuate the
energy of
interaction between the ions.
But chloroform, ether, and
hexane are not very polar,
they don't cut it down very
much.
Now this has to do with things
like the solubility or the
melting point of salts like
sodium chloride, or
tetramethylammonium iodide.
Because notice that these ions
are rather small, so the
charges are close together.
But these ions are big, so
they're
substantially further apart.
And that's going to make an
enormous difference when
you're starting to pull them
apart.
If you go to twice the distance
here, you really cut
this way down.
So sodium fluoride has a melting
point of something
like 801 C,
but cesium iodide, the same
charges with bigger ions, is
200 degrees lower in its melting
point.
And the solubilities reflect the
same thing.
It's easier to get the solids
apart if you're starting with
bigger ions.
So the big interaction is
charge-charge, but there are
others that are important, too.
Charge with dipole, so if you
have a molecule that's not
charged but has a dissymmetry in
the charge that's within
it, so it has a plus and a minus
end, then those can
interact, and that's
proportional to 1 over R
squared, so it dies away more
rapidly.
And if the dipole can orient so
that you have to average
over different ways it could be
oriented, it would be
oriented more likely in the
favorable than in the
unfavorable way, but that
depends on the temperature.
And if you have that situation
it turns out to be R to the
minus fourth over temperature,
because of how much is favored
one way or the other.
Then if you go to a charge with
something that's
non-polar, but could become
polar if it's put in the field
of another charge, so you push
the nucleus one way, the
electrons the other way.
And now you get a charge
interacting
with an induced dipole.
That depends on R to the minus
3--
1 over R cubed.
Then you could have two dipoles
interacting with one another--
that's also 1 over R cubed.
Or you could have two induced
things that are acting with
one another.
Have you ever seen that before?
How the electrons are
distributed in this one?
When they're over here-- the
ones here tend to be over
there, and when these are here,
these are here.
Where did we encounter that
before?
STUDENT: Correlation.
PROFESSOR: Correlation energies,
right.
So that turns out to be R to the
[minus]
sixth power.
So notice that these others,
other than the Coulomb, they
fall off very, very rapidly.
And they start very weak.
So you might think you could
neglect them, but there could
be a lot of them.
That's the problem when there
are many
solvent molecules around.
Now let's look at some trends in
the halides.
And whatever textbook you have
you'll find this--
When we talk about different
functional groups we're
talking about the alkyl halides
now.
Typically, chapters in all the
books you look at will start
with something about the
physical properties of those
compounds and then go on to
their chemical properties.
So this is a little bit about
physical
properties of the halides.
So here we look at the van der
Walls radius of the halogen,
X. And here we look at the bond
distance
between X and carbon.
And you notice they're almost
exactly the same.
And we learn something from
that, which is that non-bonded
distances are something like
twice bonded distances.
Because the radius of an atom is
about the same as the
distance from the nucleus of the
atom to the
nucleus of the carbon.
So that means that the covalent
radius is about half
of the van der Waals radius.
Now here's a property, the
dipole moment.
How polar is the molecule?
The dipole moment shown here,
what do you notice about that
as you go fluorine, chlorine,
bromine, iodine?
What's the first thing you
notice about the trend?
STUDENT: It doesn't work for H.
PROFESSOR: Derek?
STUDENT: There's nothing with H?
PROFESSOR: Well, I didn't put
it.
If you have H, it turns out
there is no dipole moment
because it's with methyl.
So H-CH3 is a symmetrical
molecule, and the center of
the electrons is the same as the
center of the nuclei.
But the red is a trend as you
go-- well, forget hydrogen
because it's not really a
halogen.
But here's the radius, the bond
distance.
What's special about this one,
about the orange one?
Lauren?
STUDENT: It goes the opposite
way.
PROFESSOR: Pardon me?
STUDENT: It goes the opposite
way.
It goes down.
PROFESSOR: It goes up and down,
it's not monotonic.
What do you learn when you see
trends that are not monotonic?
Matt?
STUDENT: It's dependent on two
factors.
PROFESSOR: There must be two
things going on.
But what's the other thing?
We're interested in how much
charge is separated.
Here we have CH3 and a halogen.
So the dipole moment is how big
the charges are and how
much they're separated.
Now we already see here how much
they're separated, that
is, what the distance is.
But how big is the charge?
So if we look here--
this is incidentally measured in
debye units, which is 4.8
times the charge times the
separation.
Now we know the separation and
we notice
that it's not monotonic.
And here's the charge, how many
electrons have been
transferred.
And that's quite monotonic.
But what we've seen here is that
the dipole moment is the
product of two properties--
how much charge and how much
separated.
But they're opposing trends.
As one goes up the other goes
down.
And although they're both
monotonic, one is non-linear,
more non-linear than the other.
So they don't exactly cancel one
another in going up and
down and you get weird behavior
when you have
conflicting non-linear trends.
So there were two things going
on to give the dipole moment.
Now you can see a similar kind
of thing in another measure of
the size of atoms, which is
so-called A-value.
That's how much is axial
compared to equatorial in
cyclohexane.
Axial is more crowded than
equatorial is-- we talked
about this last semester.
So if we know what the energy
difference is between axial
and equatorial, we have some
measure of how
big that group is.
So it's E axial minus energy
equatorial in kilocalories per
mole, so that measures
substituent size.
Now here are the values for the
halogens, and hydrogen
incidentally, which is defined
as zero because you're
comparing hydrogen with
hydrogen.
So here it is.
And again, you see it's not
monotonic--
it goes up and down.
So there must be two things
involved.
What are the two things?
One of the things is how big the
van der Walls radius of
the atom is, which clearly gets
bigger as you go
fluorine, chlorine, bromine,
iodine.
But why does the effect on axial
versus
equatorial go up and down.
Why doesn't it just go up?
STUDENT: The bond distance
between the carbon and the
substituent.
PROFESSOR: Because the bond gets
longer as
the atom gets bigger.
So it's not monotonic, that
suggests there's a
competition.
So here's fluorine--
that's what's shown here.
And now watch this model as I
change
from fluorine to iodine.
What happened?
The atom gets bigger, not shown
to scale, but the bond
gets longer.
So you have a larger van der
Waals radius, but it stands
off further, so it's not so
dramatic, the difference.
Now compare that if the group
there is CH3.
Because CH3 has this effective
van der Waals radius.
So that's how I decided where to
put it on this scale.
It's got the right van der Waals
radius.
But the bond distance for
carbon-carbon is much shorter
than it is for bromine and
iodine or chlorine for that--
or it's about the same as
fluorine or
a little bit bigger.
And now when we put these two
things together in order to
get the A-value--
we got this big group and it's
come in some,
compared to the halogens.
Now you see there's a really
wild outlier in this thing
because you now have a big
group, the
CH3, and it's short.
So even though the radius of
methyl is between bromine and
iodine, it's effect on this is
much bigger
because it sits in closer.
Now the boiling points of the
alkyl halides.
Here's a table--
we could have taken it from any
book, this particular one
is from the Jones text--
that shows different alkyl
groups and the hydrogen,
fluorine, chlorine, bromine,
iodine, what
are the boiling points?
Now let's just see if we can
understand this.
I'm going to go just a little
bit further because we started
late with people getting here
late, and we had that little
break in the class.
So let's look at the boiling
point.
So methane, methyl with
hydrogen, is very low boiling,
and then it gets higher and
higher and higher.
That is, the liquid tends to
hold together more, not to go
into the gas phase-- the
molecules are
holding together more.
Now the question is why.
Why when we replace hydrogen by
fluorine, by chlorine, by
bromine, by iodine does the
boiling point go up?
What causes the molecules to
hold together?
STUDENT: Intermolecular forces.
PROFESSOR: It's not covalent
bonding.
We're talking about non-bonded
interactions now.
What could make them hold
together?
We know the fundamental forces--
it's Coulomb's law as colored by
dipoles
and things like that.
STUDENT: Hydrogen bond?
PROFESSOR: Taka, pardon me?
PROFESSOR: Hydrogen bond is an
idea.
Now you're not going to get
hydrogen bonds when you don't
have hydrogen.
So the halogens that's not going
to work for.
And the next thing we're going
to talk
about is hydrogen bonds--
that'll come in the next class
now.
Any other ideas of what holds
them together?
Nate?
STUDENT: Polar interactions and
dispersion forces?
PROFESSOR: Ah, you can have
polar interactions.
So you could have dipoles
interacting, even though there
are no charges.
So let's look at the dipole
moment, which was on that
previous table.
And you see that methane has
zero, but fluorine has 1.85.
So that's going to allow the
molecules to hold together.
So raise the boiling point
because you could have them
lined up this way.
But it's not just polarity.
Because if we go across here,
the polarity went up, but then
it goes down again.
But the boiling point keeps
going up.
So there must be something else
other than these dipoles
holding together.
And that other thing is
polarizabilty.
How easy it is to shift the
electrons in the molecule, and
how many electrons there are to
shift.
So you see if you look at
fluorine, chlorine, bromine
and iodine atoms, fluorine atom
is very non-polarizable.
When you bring a charge or a
dipole near it, it doesn't
distort very much.
But chlorine distorts more,
bromine, and iodine the most
because it has the most
electrons,
the most weakly held.
And CH4 is not polar, and also
it's not very polarizable.
The hydrocarbon is not very
polarizable given that it's
five atoms and these are just
one atom.
Next time we'll start at this
point and go in and to try to
understand the boiling point of
the alkanes without the
halogen on them.
Thanks for your patience with
changing horses in midstream.